[Música]
durante su visita a polonia el
presidente estadounidense joe biden
denunció los ataques rusos a ucrania y
dijo que vladimir putin no puede
permanecer en el poder la casa blanca
aseguró que el mandatario no estaba
sufriendo un cambio de mando
se cumplen siete años de la campaña
militar liderada por arabia saudita en
yemen un conflicto que ha dejado decenas
de miles de muertos y ha provocado una
de las mayores crisis humanitarias del
mundo miles de personas salieron a las
calles de saná para conmemorar la fecha
la fiscalía de colombia reveló detalles
de los análisis hechos al fallecido
baterista de la banda foo fighters de
acuerdo con los resultados se
encontraron más de 10 tipos de
sustancias en el cuerpo de taylor
hawkins quien murió este viernes de
manera repentina en un hotel de bogotá
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz empezamos hablando de la
visita del presidente de estadounidense
joe biden a europa el mandatario cerró
su viaje con un discurso en la capital
de polonia y tuvo palabras sin
precedentes contra su homólogo ruso
vladimir putin considerando que éste no
puede seguir en el poder y llamándolo
carnicero aunque la casa blanca aclaró
que biden no estaba sugiriendo un cambio
de mando el portavoz del kremlin rechazó
estas declaraciones y añadió que no
depende del presidente de eeuu decidir
quien permanecerá en el poder en rusia
cat 6 por dios este hombre no puede
seguir en el poder
ni piensen avanzar un centímetro sobre
territorio de la otan
tenemos obligaciones sagradas tenemos la
sagrada obligación según el artículo
quinto de defender cada centímetro del
territorio de la otan
y más de cuatro semanas después de que
rusia invadiera ucrania las fuerzas
rusas siguen viendo frustrados sus
esfuerzos por capturar las principales
ciudades incluidas la capital kiev y la
segunda ciudad de ucrania kharkiv
autoridades ucranianas dicen que sus
fuerzas están ahora en la contraofensiva
en áreas que rusia ha logrado capturar
incluyendo la ciudad portuaria del mar
negro en el sur gerson y en los
suburbios del norte de kiev moscú dice
ahora que está cambiando el enfoque de
sus operaciones militares para
concentrarse en lo que llama liberar la
región oriental de donbass que ha sido
el sitio de un movimiento separatista
pro ruso en curso desde 2014 el anuncio
es visto como un posible reconocimiento
por parte de moscú del fracaso de sus
militares para lograr sus objetivos
iniciales declarados de desmilitarizar y
de clasificar todo el país
en que el sonido familiar de una sirena
antiaérea vuelva a sonar en los
suburbios del noreste de la ciudad
continúan los combates con las tropas
ucranianas montando ahora contra ataques
contra las fuerzas rusas atrincheradas
tras semanas sin avances al presidente
por la divisé lens que afirma que el
ejército de su país ha asestado fuertes
golpes a rusia al tiempo que pide que se
reanuden las negociaciones de paz
nuestras fuerzas armadas continúan
repeliendo los ataques del enemigo en el
sur del país en donde en la dirección de
jarquín y en la región de kiev al frenar
las acciones de rusia nuestros
defensores están llevando a los
dirigentes rusos a una idea simple y
lógica es necesario hablarse en donkey
trampa o gorete en la ciudad portuaria
de mariupol asediada desde el mar de
azov se han registrado combates
callejeros las autoridades de la urbe
afirman que todavía hay que evacuar a
unos 100.000 civiles los que quedan allí
describen los efectos de semanas de
bombardeos indiscriminados por parte de
rusia
si la gente está muriendo porque están
luchando porque no pueden decidir cómo
dividir el poder y nosotros estamos
sufriendo tras un mes de guerra rusia
sólo ha conseguido capturar una ciudad
importante el puerto de gerzón en el mar
negro donde según el pentágono
estadounidense las fuerzas ucranianas
están montando otra contraofensiva en un
intento de retomar el control ante la
perspectiva de un estancamiento y de las
crecientes pérdidas
moscú parece estar cambiando sus
objetivos describiendo la primera etapa
de su llamada operación militar especial
como finalizada centrándose ahora en el
control de la región oriental de donbass
donde los separatistas pro rusos han
estado luchando en una guerra de
secesión desde el año 2014
cambiamos de tema se marcó el séptimo
aniversario de la campaña militar de
arabia saudita en yemen miles de
simpatizantes sutiles marcharon en las
calles de saná un día después de varios
ataques sutiles a territorio saudita
incluyendo uno que provocó el incendio
de una instalación petrolera riad
respondió con ataques aéreos con la
muerte de ocho personas en la capital
yemení gabriel coll quien nos cuenta más
siete años de intervención militar
saudita en yemen es lo que denunciaron
los miles de personas que marcharon este
sábado en la capital yemení saná la
coalición liderada por arabia saudita
intervino en marzo de 2015 después de
que los hutíes expulsaron al gobierno
respaldado por esa misma coalición
alameda durante siete años hemos
enfrentado la brutal agresión contra
nuestro país hoy conmemoramos la firmeza
yemení la legendaria firmeza que el
pueblo yemení logró contra las fuerzas
de la arrogancia silbar estas
manifestaciones tuvieron lugar un día
después de varios ataques sutiles en
suelo saudita uno de ellos provocando el
incendio de una instalación petrolera
enreda a tan sólo 20 kilómetros del
circuito de fórmula uno del gran premio
que está previsto para este domingo los
organizadores decidieron mantener el
evento afirmando que la seguridad está
garantizada el reino árabe respondió
este sábado con ataques aéreos en la
capital yemení dejando ocho muertos
hutíes el mismo día los hutíes
anunciaron una tregua de tres días y
propusieron intercambio de prisioneros
y anunciamos unilateralmente la
suspensión de los ataques con misiles y
drones y todas las acciones militares
hacia el reino de arabia saudita por
tierra mar y aire durante un período de
tres días afirmamos nuestra disposición
a convertir esta declaración en un
compromiso definitivo firme y permanente
si el reino de arabia saudita anuncia y
se compromete a poner fin al asedio y a
detener sus incursiones aéreas en el
territorio de la república de yemen de
una vez por todas al mam la gente hoy
día ven a él gestar el conflicto ya ha
dejado decenas de miles de muertos y ha
llevado a yemen al borde de la hambruna
y en otras noticias este viernes el
baterista de foo fighters taylor hawkins
murió de forma repentina en el hotel en
el que se hospedaba en bogotá la capital
colombiana según la fiscalía hawkins
consumió opioides marihuana y
antidepresivos antes de morir este
sábado muchos fans le rindieron homenaje
al bar santana nos amplia
la muerte del baterista de foo fighters
teilón hopkins hace tan solo un día ha
dejado conmocionados a cientos de miles
de fans en bogotá a colombia algunos de
ellos le rindieron homenaje y
prometieron no olvidar su legado
a seguir
todos son importantes pero creo que
el baterista de foo fighters tenía
planeado tocar junto a la banda en un
importante festival colombiano el
estéreo picnic donde miles de fans lo
esperaban hopkins era uno de los
miembros más importantes del grupo
musical al que se unió a finales de los
90 y el que siempre aparecía junto al
vocalista dave grohl en las entrevistas
también sirvió de inspiración para
muchos músicos o sea duro yo toco la
batería entonces él ha sido como una
inspiración muy grande
la última y su muerte que fuera tan
repentina quería hacerle un homenaje a
una de mis bandas favoritas un gran
artista al exterior rock kings
un baterista reconocido a nivel mundial
no solo como músico sino
su parte espiritual él era una persona
muy alegre y se identificaba con la
gente por eso ahora son muchos los que
lloran su pérdida y sobre todo agradecen
su contribución al mundo de la música y
el rock por décadas
y como cada último sábado de marzo se
celebró la hora del planeta' durante 60
minutos entre las 20 30 y las 21 30
horas de cada país la humanidad estuvo
llamada a apagar las luces y
dispositivos electrónicos de manera
voluntaria para generar conciencia sobre
las acciones que debemos tomar contra la
crisis climática desde parís hasta
grecia en nueva york' los principales
monumentos del mundo se apagaron
y despedimos esta emisión de noticias
con las imágenes del gran regreso de la
batalla de flores uno de los principales
eventos del carnaval de barranquilla en
colombia el segundo carnaval más
importante de américa latina al ritmo de
la música más de 10.000 personas con
disfraces y decoradas carrozas hicieron
parte del tradicional desfile en 2021 el
evento fue suspendido y este año sufrió
retrasos debido a las medidas sanitarias
destinadas a frenar el avance del cob el
[Aplausos]
así despedimos este informativo en
france 24 gracias por acompañarnos
continúen con toda nuestra programación
[Música]